welcome to this video playing baby baby
fish up from Portugal Kings Indian this
is a no new opponent didn't really
remember this is a kind of a you have an
extraordinary name now plating before ok
Ashley Bishop g5 that's a good sideline
in the Kings Indian something that I
have recommended myself in this older
video series that I've did for my
channel the d4 a patron I am that's an
interesting way to play taking with the
e pawn yeah don't know let's do it let's
do that but really prefer white yeah
this is this is why I recommended this
line so always a bit tricky if they play
the stuff against you that you like
yourself for the other color and Nell
form it's one of the issues why it is
very active pieces
okay that looks very good for what
really let's get out of this diagonal
there okay
hmm still not not very nice he's not
threatening anything there but this is a
bit of an annoying pressure
yeah I don't see a good idea there then
you can take f6 and take h6 but this is
I think not realizable I it's even
technically bad time I'm winning the
Queen there Bishop f6 Bishop f6 queen
age 6 Bishop g5 so that's not working at
all yeah if you place like Luke a to e
you know it doesn't you played the rook
there I really no no what what my move
is what about this can i maybe yeah it
looks fishy but I'm trying to play for
f5 here getting some control were like
on if controlling a 4 and so on it
doesn't look good really doesn't Queen D
for maybe rupee 5 is still ok
quit g5 would be nice to play maybe
Queen to e5 those kind of moves are good
if I can get them in but probably I
won't yeah this is good and I was my
plan was f5 but he can just go G for
them and I'm in big trouble Tim but I
have no others I have another g4 I can
go back and try to play this position
it's not not great but oh I totally
overlooked that he directly comes there
when he looked at rook to his six or
something
check yeah queen d 4 is good
there was a terrible opening result
really a terrible opening
remarkably bad I'm happy if he takes
this rook to be honest if I can get rid
of this night I would really reconsider
not to not to take him if I were white
him jack I played it I know he played it
exactly like it should be played and I
knew that but rookie six now is strong
okay
yeah no II saw it took him took him 12
moves but um yeah
after this he has a real gift tool
can never really take this rook on the
really no circumstance I can no it's
it's it's it's it's lost anyway whatever
and those kind of moves always show you
that you really don't have absolutely
nothing that you can do you
maybe night g75 or something I mean it's
just lost of course but maybe can do
something yeah maybe resigning as a is
something that I should time warning
consider
yeah I am it's not good how many
policies by the way it gets honey right
forum for points I don't even have if
the slightest slightest trick or
anything here cannot move any of those
pieces only thing I can hope for is
something like okay d6 Bishop c6 or some
miracle even rookie to as possible check
check I can take age 6 or this one check
I'm getting this check in 27 is just
easy why is he not doing that check
everything wins
check check check check draw I'll check
check check check check check check
check it's that some chicks at the end
but ok it's very deserved victory of
course I kind of I don't know a little
bit strange why he didn't finish me off
earlier at Queenie seven and stuff like
that what kind of a countess is anyway I
never played him right really never
pretty new account yeah he he had just
had a very good position out of the
opening yeah I know this idea with you
takes I did something that I that I have
played myself I don't really know a good
recipe against it and the way it went
you really had a great position here
this is just grateful right this is this
thing Black has no idea in terms of
active plane and why just has fantastic
pieces so he is very active too it's
really it's really really bad already
yeah maybe 90 form just trading more
stuff instead of this yeah this is you
know I really I overlooked that he has
94 so quickly which kills this
traditional to me chatham yeah after
that this is just this is just a
completely losing thing yeah bad opening
better opening result he played exactly
how it how it should be played
okay thanks for watching